sur ce véhicule on a retiré le moteur
thermique
c'est la spécialité de l'entreprise car
watts remplacer le moteur thermique par
un système électrique une activité sur
des véhicules lourds comme sur cette
voiture de safari un moteur électrique
donc cette fois ci c'est un aimant
permanent avec son contrôleur moteur et
tous les auxiliaires nécessaires
électrification d'un véhicule pour
alimenter ce moteur électrique on a
besoin d'une batterie donc là je vous
présente une batterie issus de seconde
vie une batterie reconfigurer ce projet
véhicule électrique pour safari atteint
déjà plusieurs dizaines de commandes à
venir une phase d'industrialisation en
collaboration avec des entreprises en
tanzanie
il ya déjà 4 kills d'électrification qui
sont partis sur place qui viennent d
arriver ils viennent d'être dédouanés
nos équipes techniques vont aller sur
place pour les mettre en oeuvre à partir
de novembre
né en 2014 car wattré utilisent des
batteries son principal fournisseur le
groupe renault avec des systèmes
électriques de véhicules zoé et kangoo
en juillet 2019 elle décide de
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
nous paraissait pertinent d'aller dans
ce que j'appellerais l'automotive valais
les compétences on les trouve localement
alors en plus des compétences humaines
issues où il ya tout un tissu de petites
sociétés de la connectique de la
mécanique de la transformation qui pour
nous est essentielle autre type de
production avec comme clients le groupe
air france l'équipement des véhicules
présents sur les pistes d'aéroports
comme les tapis pour mettre les bagages
dans les avions à partir de batteries
kangoo on part d'une batterie renault
kangoo de deuxième vie qu'on va
démontée pour pouvoir récupérer une
partie donc des modules la société
comptera douze salariés à la fin de
l'année son chiffre d'affaires va passer
de 20000 euros fin 2010 8 à 500000 euros
fin 2019